[موسيقى]
اسعد الله اوقاتكم بكل خير مشاهدينا
نحييكم الى بانوراما مشاهدينا ومتابعينا
نعود في هذه الحلقه لمقابله خاصه بها وزير
الخارجيه الامريكان طوني بليكن قناه
العربيه ونناقش ما جاء فيها وفي العناوين
في مقابله خاصه مع العربيه ماذا قال بلنكن
عن العلاقات مع السعوديه ولماذا كانت
واشنطن متخوفه من قرار اوبك بلس
يمكن اكد رفض اي عمليه تركيه في شمال
السوري ما اسباب المعارضه واشنطنه ولماذا
ترفض التطبيعه معا نظام الاسد
[تصفيق]
يمكن تحدث عن خيارات اخرى للتعامل مع
الملف النووي الايراني حاله فشل
الدبلوماسيه ما هي خيارات واشنطن
[موسيقى]
في مقابله خاصه بها قناه العربيه خلال
زيارته هي الشارقه الخطيئه يتناول وزير
الخارجيه الامريكي انطونيو جمله من
الملفات العربيه والاقليميه كما تتطرق الى
العلاقات بين الولايات المتحده والمملكه
العربيه السعوديه حول العلاقات بين واشنطن
والرياض قالب لينكن انها ثابته وتطور
بطريقه فعاله وقويه مؤكدا عمقه هذه
العلاقه وتطورها باستمرار مع الادارات
كافه الوزير الامريكي قال ان الاداره
الحاليه تعمل على دعم تطوير هذه العلاقات
كما اشار الى المساعده التي تبذلها
الاداره الامريكيه مع المملكه العربيه
السعوديه لانهاء الحرب في اليمن وفي سياق
حديثه اشار وزير الخارجيه الامريكي الى
بعض المخاوف التي كانت موجوده بعد قرار
اوبك بلس تخفي
لكنه اوضح انه منذ ذلك الحين اظهرت
السعوديه علامات ايجابيه بدعمها ليوكرانيا
ضد الحرب الروسيه وبتاييدها لقرارات مجلس
الامن
مع السعوديه منذ عقود واجيال وعبر ادارات
امريكيه مختلفه وسنعمل كل ما بوسعنا
للتاكد من ان العلاقه مع الرياض مستمره
كان لدينا بعض المخاوف بعد قرار اوبك بلس
تخفيض انتاج النفط منذ ذلك الحين السعوديه
اظهرت على علامات ايجابيه بدعملها
الاوكرانيا ضد الحرب الروسيه والتاييدها
لقرارات مجلس الامن والعلاقات مستمره
بالتطور للتاكد من انها ستعزز
مصالحناها بعباس السياسي اهلا بكمين واسم
حالي ان ابدا مع الاستاذ ايهاب عباس من
واشنطن همم في فهم اولي لهذه التصريحات في
الواقعه استاذ ايهاب لان وزير الخارجيه
الامريكيه يعطونيو لما تحدث عن العلا
ثنائيه الوصيده والمتينه بينه وبين اوبين
واشنطن وبين المملكه العربيه السعوديه
استذكر مخاوف واشنطن من قرار اوبك بلس الى
اي مدا هذا القرار مثل فعليا قلقا حقيقيا
لاداره بيضاء
من الرياض وبكل المشاهدين اينما كانوا في
الواقع يعني اداره جو بايدا وستتحدث
بصراحه بغض النظر عن انتربلنكن اجره
مقابله مع العربيه ام لا وتحدث فيها بشكل
ناعم جدا ل- اا توضيح العلاقات الامريكيه
السعوديه واشنطن خسرت الكثير على مدار
عامين من محاوله همم يعني ان تسيء الى
علاقاتها المتينه من المفترض والمهمه مع
المملكه العربيه السعوديه على مدار 10
سنوات وادرك وادرك ذلك متاخرا جدا الى ان
جاءت الزياره التي قام بها الرئيس الحالي
الى المملكه ولقائه بولي العهد السعودي
طبعا بالملك همم سلمان وبكل المسؤولين
السعوديه في هذا التوقيت ادركت واشنطن همم
يعني سوء ادارتها لهذه العلاقات مع اهم
حديث الاستراتيجي لها في منطقه الشرق
الاوسط والتي ادت الى كثير من تاخر في
عمليات كان من المفترض ان تنج فيها واشنطن
بشكل كبير وحاسم اتحدث عن الملف الايراني
نتحدث عن ملف ال- اا عوده الشرعيه في
اليمن ودعم التحالف العربي لعوده الشرعيه
هناك وملفات اخرى كثيره وعلى راسها طبعا
ومن بينها مكافحه الارهاب والملفات
الاقتصاديه ف- فكره قرار اوبك بلس والتزام
المملكه العربيه السعوديه والدول المنتجه
والمصدره للنفط بالحدود المسموح بها طبقا
لهذه المنظمه التي تدير شؤون النفط على
مستوى العالم هو كان يؤرق الولايات
المتحده واداره جوباين لانهم كانوا
يعتقدون ان تخفيض الانتاج من شانه ان يرفع
الاسعار باعلى من معدلاتها ويؤدي الى
ازمات همم في همم كل دول العالم صحيح في
الولايات المتحده كانت هناك ازمه ولكن من
خلق هذه الازمه ليست المملكه العربيه
السعوديه ليست اوبل كلاس من خلقها هو
اداره جو بايدن بعدم همم ان تكون لديها
حنكه في التعامل مع الملف الروسي
الاوكراني الذي اوصل للحاله القضيه في
الداخل الامريكي الى وضع اد معه ان تسحب
الولايات المتحده من احتياطي احتياطياتها
الاستراتيجيه من النفط ومن ثم تريد ان
تدفع يعني تدفع همم المملكه العربيه
السعوديه او الدول بلس ثمن هذا السحب
وثمان هذا
ايهاب ربط بين هذه الحرب الاوكرانيه
الروسيه وبين همم اجابته بخصوص
وهنا سؤال هذا جاسم في سؤال عن اوباك
بلاست تحدث عن هذه القلق او هذا القلق عن
هذه المخاوف ولكن فيما بعد قلبي انه كنا
قلقين من همم قرار المملكه العربيه
السعوديه هناك فيما بعد راينا قرار
المملكه داخل مجلس الامن في علاقه مع
الحرب الاوكرانيه الروسيه همم فهمنا بان
توجه المملكه ايجابي تجاهنا همم الى هذه
الدرجه يفكر او تفكر الاداره الامريكيه في
موقف المملكه عموما من هذه الاداره بمعنى
ان بتوع لا يقتصر فقط على اوبك بلس
مساء الخير
ايهاب في حاله القلق والارتباك في الاداره
الامريكيه وفي تعاملها مع السعوديه تحديدا
المساله بلوك بلس واضحه تماما نعتقد انها
يعني صار اصبحت مثلا مفهومه وتماما هذا
قرار منظمات تعنى بتحديد العلاقه بين
المنتجين المشاركين بما يضمن استقرار
توازن السوق وكانت طلب الامريكي ايضا واضح
حسب البيان السعودي وقته وكان طلب سياسي
انتخابي لا علاقه له بالمصل اقتصاديه كانت
تريد ان تجير سعوديه لم تكون صاحبه قرار
وايضا السعوديه كانت يعني لم تكون هي
المساله هي اللي اتخذت هذا القرار اتخذتها
المنظمه اللي تضم 23 دوله منتجه النفط
بهذا الاساس بما المصالحه ويحمي ايضا
المصالحين انا اعتقد يعني الان همم يعني
صحيح فيه اليوم همم تصريحات الوزير هي
تعبر عن حاله تحول في الاداره السياسيه
العلاقه السعوديه امريكيه لها مستويه
مستوى داخلي ثابت وكامل ومستمر وهذا قائم
على العلاقات والمصالح المشتركه والتعاون
الامني في المنطقه وملفات كثيره لا تحصى
قائمه بين السعوديه وامريكا مهما كانت
يعني الطبقه السياسيه تختلف او تستخدم او
تتوتر في العلاقات لكن هذا الجانب دائما
كان محصنا ومحمي من هذه التقلبات اليوم
الخطاب يعني اختلف انا اعتقد انه تمت
مراجعه العلاقات بين الطرفين والمراجعه
تمت لصالح السعوديه بمعنى انه لما كانت
تريد الامريكي تطرح انه مراجعه العلاقات
مع السعوديه ايضا مثل ما ذكرت الاميره
ريما نحن ايضا نرغب في مراجعه العلاقات مع
امريكا رجعت العلاقات بما يحقق او يتناغم
او يتطابق مع الرؤيه السعوديه الجديده في
التعامل مع المنطقه والمصالحها وخدمه
اهدافها وبالتالي نحن نشهد اختلافنا في
تصريحات البنك الاهلي اللي كان يعتبر انه
قرار اوبو بلس ليس قرار حليب اليوم كان
يقول احنا تجاوزنا ويحاول ان يرحل المساله
الى انه في خطوات قامت فيها السعوديه نعم
العلاقه مهمه العلاقه ثابته بغض النظر عن
كل التصريحات السياسيه العلاقه لها لها
وشائج مقومات حيه تدعمها من حيث الزمن ومن
حيث التماسك وبالتالي كل هذه التصريحات
اعتقد انه لعل الاداره الامريكيه بدات تعي
وتستوعب هذه التغيرات وبدات يعني تغير لغه
خطاب هل الذي كان متشنجاجا
اداره بعيدا تتحدث
نعم
امريكيه ان حجم المشاكل الموجوده في
المنطقه لا يمكن تهتم بدون التعاون مع
المملكه العربيه السعوديه وانها اتخذت
ايضا قرارات خاطئه فهي تحاول الان ان ترمم
هذا جهودها في المنطقه وهذا الترميم يقتضي
اصلا اعاده الجدوى الى هذه العلاقات
السياسيه
كذلك تحدث عن ان هذه العلاقه مستمره وفي
تطور وهنا سؤال استاذ ايهاب ما شكل هذا
التطور الذي تقراه او تطمح له واشنطن في
علاقتها ثنائيه مع المملكه العربيه
السعوديه حنيف صديق اي شكل من اشكال
التطور
يعني انا اعتقد ان المملكه العربيه
السعوديه بغض النظر عن اي خلافات تنشر بين
الولايات المتحده والسعوديه في اي من
الملفات الى انها في نهايه المطاف هي حليف
استراتيجي قوي ومهم جدا للولايات المتحده
على مستوى العالم
وربما الاهم على مستوى الاقليم وبدون
المملكه العربيه السعوديه لن تستطيع
الولايات المتحده اي ما كانت هذه الاداره
ديمقراطيه او جمهوريه ان تتعامل مع كثير
من الملفات فيها بشكل حازم وحاسم سواء
كانت هذه الملفات اقتصاديه تجاريه سياسيه
اجتماعيه حتى وطبعا من بينها العسكريه
ومكافحه الارهاب الى اخرهم وبالتالي الذي
تعول عليه الاداره الامريكيه اليوم اذا ما
كانت تغير بالفعل نهجها من خلال تصريحات
المختلفه منذ زياره بيض الى المملكه
العربيه السعوديه وحتى اليوم اعتقد اولا
ان يجب ان يكون هناك دعم للشريك الحليف
والاستراتيجي الذي تتحدث عنه اليوم انه
بينك وبينه مصالح وعلاقات استراتيجيه قويه
كما قال بلانكن طيب هذه المصالح قتل
استراتيجيه القويه في البدايه يجب ان تهتم
بالمسائل الامنيه والمسائل الامنيه متعلقه
ولا تحدث بكل صراحه مثلا بالحرب التي
تخوضها المملكه العربيه السعوديه من اجل
الشرعيه في اليمن واعاده هذا البلد الى
مساره الصحيح لماذا اوقفت اداره جو بايدن
المساعدات اللوجستيه والاستراتيجيه لهذا
التحالف العربي لعوده الشرعيه في اليمن
يجب ان يعود هذا
الدعم بشكل كبير يجب ان تضع جماعه
الحوثيين الارهابيه على قوائم الارهاب يجب
ان تتعامل مع ملف ايران بشكل حازم وحاسم
والا تخوض مره اخرى مفاوضات لا طائل منها
اغضبت كل الدول ال- ال- الحلفاء لها في
المنطقه لانها تدع ايران تتعامل بازرعها
الارهابيه في المنطقه بشكل همم يعني يزعج
دول الجوار ودول الجوار يعني ما زال تضبط
النفس امام النظام الايراني بالاضافه
لملفات اخرى كثيره من بينها التعامل
الاقتصادي والتجاري
هذه هي النقطه يعني تحدثت على الجانب
الامني ولكن هناك كذلك جانب اقتصادي مهم
جدا للبلدين استاذه جاسر بالعوده الى اوبك
بلس والذي اعتبر توجيهات امريكيه فيما بعد
بان القرار كان صائب وكان في صالح النظام
العالمي كذلك واتخذته مجموعه من الدول ولا
تحمل فقط مسئوليه المملكه العربيه
السعوديه ولكن ااه اقتصاديا هل هناك شكل
من اشكال تطور العلاقات الذي تقراه تطمح
له واشنطن في هذه المرحله
نتفق على مثلا لعل المملكه في السابق كانت
يعني
بوصلتها امريكيه غالبا وليست يعني متنوعه
المملكه مع رؤيه المملكه 2030 اصبحت
البوصله متنوعه تقوم على الخيارات
المتعدده وعلى ما يحقق هذه الرؤيه ويلبي
متطلباتها بشكل اساسي بالدرجه الاولى اذا
هذا التبدل هذا يحتم ايضا ويحدد النمط
العلاقات الاقتصاديه مع الولايات المتحده
صحيح هناك مناطق ثابته لا يمكن سنه نقاط
تعاون مستقره ومستديمه لكن هناك خيارات
اخرى هذا المجال انفتح في المملكه
وتعدد على القياس ولذلك في جانب اخر جانب
مهم مرتبط بهذا التنور بمعنى المملكه
دائما تختار اليوم في رؤيه المملكه 20 في
اي مشروع الطرف الاكثر ملائمه هناك مشكله
نعتقد نشات في الفتره الاخيره التي ثقه في
الولايات المتحده بمعنى انه اذا كان هناك
دولتان احداهم الولايات المتحده هم
الشريكان المناسبا للمملكه في هذه النقطه
فانه قد كنا قلق من الولايات المتحده بس
مواقف السياسيه او الاختلال الثقه في
طريقه التعامل او تحويل التعاملات
والعلاقات الاقتصاديه الى موضوعات سياسيه
بما فيها التدخل الجانب فبالتالي لهذا سيء
يجعل المملكه قلقه وتذهب الى الطرف الاخر
بحثا عن الطمانينه وبحثا لان الرؤيه ليس
لا تراها ليست مشاريع مغلقه بناء مستقبل
كامل
هل ترى بان المتغيرات الجو السياسيه كذلك
بان الحرب الاوكرانيه الروسيه التي عرضت
الكثير من الحقائق حقيقه هل تعتقد بان هذه
المرحله تساعد كذلك على ان تتمكن الدول
ومن بينها المملكه العربيه السعوديه بان
تتعاون مع واسطن ولكن كذلك بان تبقي مصالح
قائمه مع دول اخرى قد لا تتفق هذه الدول
في خطوط عريضه مع الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه
هناك عنوان رئيس ينعتقد للعلاقات السعوديه
الامريكيه يجب ان يكون مصالحنا وقيامنا
المشتركه ليست مصالحه واشنطن هذه نقطه
مهمه المملكه لا تتعامل مع صالح واشنطن
وصالح واشنطن تعني واشنطن نفسه نحن تكلم
على المصالح
والقيم المشتركه التي يمكن ان نعمل فيها
سويه نعم هذا التنوع على فكره يعني هي
نعتقد الحرب الازمه الروسيه الاوكرانيه
كشفت هذا الجانب لكن التحرك السعودي قبل
هذا المساله تحرك السعودي كان مستمر في
هذا الجانب على مراحل متعدده لكن نقول انه
احدث نوع من الاستفادات السياسيه الازمه
الروسيه الاوكرانيه وهناك صار تاويل او
محاوله تحميل يعني مثلا العلاقه العلاقه
المملكه مثلا مع الصين علاقه قويه ومتينه
من سابق وليست حديثه وليست وليده اليوم
وليست نهايه عن الازمه وليست مرتب عليها
علاقه بينهما مسارات متعدده وقويه في جانب
وبالتالي كانت تمثل خيار فبالتالي عمليه
تحميل ان هذه العلاقه وهذا التطور في
العلاقه كان نتيجه الازمه او انه توجه
يمينا ويسارا هذا ت- تفسير سياسي وهذا
تفسير محاوله ضاغط وتشويه لطريقه الاداء
الحكوميه بالتالي انا اللي اتمنى ان
الاداره الملكيه اليوم تدخل هي في مرحله
الاستعام ان حاله الصخب السياسي وحاله
الخطاب السياسي الصاخب الذي كانت تعتمده
الاداره في السنتين اوليتين لعلها الان
بدها تدرك نتيجه تحولات المهمه ونتيجه
تراجع دورها ونتيجه يعني اخفاءاتها انها
لابد ان تتفاهم وتتعامل بشكل مختلف
وبالتالي هذا تحول المرحب فيه تماما
الولايات المتحده شريك لك لا شك في ذلك
وهو شركه الامن والتعامل تم يعني المملكه
والولايات المتحده حتى في عزه التوتر
السياسي المعني بالطبقه الخارجيه كان هناك
التعاون في المساله سوريا سوريا
وافغانستان وفي المنطقه وفي تحقيق
الاستقرار وفي مساله الدوله فلسطين وفي
الاستقرار في الدول العربيه وفي حفظ يعني
من الطاقه دوليه وايضا في التعاملات كثيره
كقائم هو مستمره بعيدا عن التعاون العسكري
الثنائي في مساله بينهم صحيح جوانب هذه
هذا نمط العلاقه هذا نمط يعني من النماط
المتفرده وحيده اللي هي الشراكه انديه
وهذه نقطه مهمه الصراكنديه شركاء بمحقق
مصالحنا وقيم من المشتركه هذه الرساله انا
كتبتها
هذه العباره لانقلها لضيف الاستاذ ايهاب
استاذ ايهاب هذه الشراكه النديه فيما يخص
كل ما هو اتفاقيات اقتصاديه انطلاقا من
اوبلاس هل تعتقد كما يرى كثر او ربما
تعارض هذه القراءه بان قرار اوبيك بلاس
الاخير بخصفظ انتاج النفط كان اول مؤشر
على ان الامور قد تغيرت على ان شكل هذه
العلاقه يمكن ان تختلف مع احترام مصالح
المجموعه
اتفق مع هذه الرؤيا ان واشنطن تفاجات
بقرار مجموعه دول اوبك بلس وربما تفاجات
بقرار الدول العربيه تحديدا ايضا وعلى
راسها المملكه العربيه السعوديه في هذا
الاطار وكانت هناك امنيه لدى واشنطن ان
تاخذ الدول العربيه مجتمعه ومن بين
المملكه العربيه السعوديه قرارا بان تاخذ
جانب الولايات المتحده والدول الغربيه
مثلا في الحرب الروسيه الاخرانيه ولكن
الدول العربيه في الواقع اخذت موقف محايد
هذا الموقف المحايد جعل لهذه الدول
العربيه قدرات في ان تلعب ادوار لتوازن
ايه عمل توازن في هذه الحرب ادوار سلميه
طبعا اا نتذكر ان هناك كانت دور سعودي على
ما اتذكر في اعاده او تبادل اثرى بين
روسيا بين اسرى بين روسيا واوكرانيا خلال
الفتره الماضيه كان هناك ادوار همم
التعامل في مجال الطاقه بشكل ايضا متوازن
وقرار اوبك كلاس كان قرارا من وجهه نظري
كان قرارا حكيما لان اوبل بلاس لا تاخذ
قرارات لمصلحه الولايات المتحده هي تاخذ
قرارات لمصلحه الدول المنتجه للنفط
وللمستهلكين والاستقرار اسعار النفط لكن
كما قلت قبل ذلك همم لا يجب ان تتحمل
المملكه العربيه السعوديه ولا اوبك كلاس
اي قرارات خاطئه تاخذها اي دوله من الدول
ومن هذه الدول الولايات المتحده كان من
الممكن لاداره بايضا ان تنهي هذا الصراع
او تجعله لا يبدا اصلا الروسي الاوكراني
منذ بدايته وهذا ما عبر عنه الرئيس السابق
عندما قال له كنت رئيسا لامريكا وحدث ما
حدث لكنت تصرفت بشكل يجعل هذه الحرب لا
تقوم اصلا بسبب علاقاته الطيبه مع روسيا
وقدرته على التاثير على اوكرانيا امريكا
شكرا جزيلا على مشاركتنا هذا الجزء من
النقاش ايهاب عباس منه واشنطن المحلل
السيا سيوه همم جاسر جاسر من الرياض
الكاتبه الصحفي شكرا لكم